Guten Abend.
Hallo, ich bin Foucaan Baghan und bin auf dieser Station Arztdienstabende Arztdietig.
Also ich würde gerne mit Ihnen diese Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Melanie Goldstein.
Melanie Goldstein.
Goldstein, ja.
Können Sie Ihr Vorname langsam bestabieren?
Frau Goldstein.
Melanie schreibt sich M-E-L-A-N-I-Melanie
und der Nachname Goldstein-G-O-L-D-S-T-E-I-N.
Goldstein.
Gut, und wie alt sind Sie, Frau Goldstein?
58.
Wann wurden Sie geboren?
21. Juli 1965.
Okay, und wie groß sind Sie?
1,72 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
72 kg.
Haben Sie ein Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin?
Ja, Hausarzt ist Dr. Brinkmann.
Brinkmann.
Frau Goldstein, was hat sie zu uns geführt?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Seit 3 Stunden habe ich ganz heftige Kopfschmerzen.
Ich halte das gar nicht mehr aus.
Sie gingen ganz plötzlich los und müssen mir helfen.
Das ist ganz stark, ganz schlimm.
Seit 3 Stunden oder?
Und können Sie, wo genau sind die Schmerzen, können Sie es zeigen?
Eigentlich sind die im ganzen Kopf.
Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass es irgendwo an einer Stelle besonders ist.
Und sind Sie irgendwo in der Frau Goldstein?
Nein, nur im Kopf.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Vorhanden, Stischende, wie schätzen Sie ein?
Ich würde sagen, Sie sind mehr dumpf.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, als ob der Kopf platzen würde.
Als ob es raus will, aus dem Kopf.
Okay.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Wenn 1 leichter und 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen sind?
8.
Okay.
Und gibt es etwas, was diese Schmerzen per Linderdurlöfersteckt?
Also ich muss mich ruhig hinsetzen.
Oder ich habe mehr auch gelegen,
weil ich trau mich gar nicht aufzustehen,
weil mir auch so schwindelig ist.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Auslöfer für diese Schmerzen bemerkten?
Nein, ich habe keine Erklärung.
Das ging ganz plötzlich los.
Das ging auch nicht langsam los,
sondern das ging ziemlich schnell los.
In weniger Minuten.
Und haben Sie sich durchgehen?
Ja, mein Sehen ist auch nicht so gut jetzt in den letzten 1,5 Stunden.
Das hat sich jetzt verschlechtert.
Ich muss sehr angestrengt sehen und ich sehe auch etwas verschwommen.
Gibt es diese 6 Stöngen, die beide Augen oder nur eine?
Nein, ich glaube mit beiden Augen.
Die beiden Augen?
Ich unterschreibe es.
Hatten Sie solche Schmerzen schon einmal?
Nein, so was habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich glaube sonst eigentlich ganz selten Kopfschmerzen,
aber überhaupt nicht so stark.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Ihnen ist schwindelig
und haben Sie Erbruchchen?
Ja, mir war ziemlich von Anfang an dann übel
und ich habe es seither 3 Mal erbrach.
Und haben Sie Ihre Blutdruck gemessen?
Nein, den habe ich jetzt in der Aufregung nicht gemessen,
aber ich habe hohen Blutdruck.
Sie haben schon einen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese hohen Blutdruck?
Also bekannt ist er so richtig seit 5 Jahren.
5 Jahre?
Nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Ja, nehm ich einen Moment, ich habe mir das auf dem Zettel stehen.
Walzatan, 5, nehm ich eine Tablette morgens und eine abends.
Nehmen Sie diese Medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Ja, regelmäßig.
Und dann nehme ich auch noch Metopolol.
25 steht darauf.
1 morgens und eine abends.
Und sind Ihnen eine Kribende oder Taubheitsgefühl oder
Erlehmung erscheinungen bekannt?
Ne, sowas habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt, bevor die sich mehr sind
aufgetreten sind?
Na kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern, also ich habe keinen
Unfall gehabt, ich bin nicht gestürzt.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Und haben Sie also noch etwas bemerkt oder?
Ne, ne.
Also ganz vordergrund stehen diese starken Schmerzen.
Ganz starker Schmerzen, okay.
Wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe, da haben Sie seit 3 Stunden
erst mal aufgetretene heftige Kopfschmerzen,
die dunkelartige Schmerzen sind, ohne Schmerzstrahlung.
Die Schmerzen strachen nirgendwo aus.
Ja.
Okay.
Und wie ist die Appetit?
Haben Sie Appetitprobleme oder?
Nein, normalerweise nicht.
Aber jetzt seit diesen 3 Stunden habe ich keinen Appetit.
Da ist mir ja übel und habe ich ja gebrochen,
habe ich auch nichts gegessen.
Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen oder?
Nein, nicht nicht.
Okay.
Und wie ist der Schlaf?
Malerweise ist der Schlaf gut, ich habe da keine Probleme.
Schlafen.
Schürzen Sie ihn danach oder nun?
Nein, nein.
Wir höchstens, wenn es so warm ist,
in der Zeit war es ja nicht so warm,
aber wenn es richtig warm ist, dann schwitzt sich auch mal.
Aber das ist in Deutschland ja nicht so oft.
Sie hatten diese Schmerzen ein Erstmal.
Ja.
Und haben Sie Fibau oder?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Haben Sie eine Nackensteifigkeit bemerkt?
Nackensteifigkeit.
Also wenn ich den Kopf so bewege oder so,
habe ich nicht so.
Haben Sie die Gedechnisprobleme bemerkt?
Erinnern Sie sich an alle Dinge?
Normalerweise nicht, aber ich habe jetzt so den Eindruck,
die letzten drei Stunden, da aufgrund der Schmerzen,
habe ich nicht so richtig, da bin ich nicht so richtig fit,
nicht so richtig dran.
Waren Sie unmächtig, Bragolstein?
Ich glaube nicht.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Abworter zugenommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Masalassen oder mit der Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Stuhlgang schon, weil ich habe eine Milchzuckerunverträglichkeit.
Das hat länger gedauert, bis das festgestellt worden ist.
Da hatte ich schon häufiger Probleme, Blähungen und Durchfall.
Aber seitdem das jetzt bekannt ist und ich mich von der Ernährung hier
darauf einstelle, dann ist das viel besser geworden.
Okay, sehr gut.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie keine Umfalt gehabt haben.
Sind Sie sicher dafür?
In den letzten zwei Wochen haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt?
Nein, ich habe keinen Unfall gehabt.
Ist Ihnen eine Ohrensausen bekannt?
Ohrensausen, also Geräusche im Ohr oder so?
Ja, genau, Ohrengeräusche.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Sie leiden an eine Bluthochdruck seit fünf Jahren.
Haben Sie sonst noch etwas,
irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen oder?
Dieses Milchzuckerunverträglichkeit.
Damals hier heißt es auch Reizdarm.
Aber Milchzuckerunverträglichkeit habe ich,
aber die ist jetzt besser geworden,
weil ich eine gewisse Ernährung mich etwas anders,
indem ich Milch zufällig habe.
Und ich habe noch auf beiden Augen einen grünen Stahl.
Okay.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert oder stationär behandelt?
Operiert worden bin ich als Kind.
Da wurde ich an den Mandeln operiert.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr genau, wie alt ich da war
und ich wurde auch als Kind am Blinddam operiert.
Und vor vier Jahren wurde ich an der linken Niere operiert
wegen Nierenstein.
Er musste durch eine Operation entfernt werden
aus dem Nierenbecken.
Der war so groß und führte dort zu Komplikationen.
Können Sie es wiederholen?
Ich wollte sicher sein.
Nierenstein.
Sie haben einen Nierenstein operiert.
Ja, linken Nieren.
Und war das Komplikationen noch so?
Ja, jetzt ist das gut.
Ich gehe immer wieder zur Kontrolle, zum Uruloben,
aber das ist in Ordnung.
Okay.
Sie nehmen täglich Walzartan 5 mg
und Metacrol 25 mg ein.
Dann gibt es noch etwas als Medikamente.
Für den grünen Stah nehme ich jeden Tag Tropfen.
Wissen Sie diese Name?
Ja, die Name habe ich mir gemerkt.
Der heißt Team Moptol.
Team Moptol Augen Tropfen.
Orgens einen Tropfen jeweils in ein Auge
und Abends jeweils in jedes Auge jeweils einen Tropfen.
Ja, okay.
Da waren die letzten Kontrollen beim Augenarzt aber ganz gut.
Der Augenarzt sagte, sie ist an der Grenze,
aber er war schon ganz zufrieden.
Das war sehr gut.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente gegen diese Schmerzen ein?
In letzten 3 Stunden?
Ja, ich habe mal eine Paraziltamol genommen,
aber die hat überhaupt nicht gewirkt.
Das hat Ihnen nicht geholfen?
Sind Sie gegen Corona und Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zum Hausarzt
und der macht dann diese Gesundheitscheckups
und prüft den Impfpass und da ist ja alles gut.
Sehr gut.
Können Sie in den letzten 6 Monaten im Ausland?
Nein, nein, nein.
Frau Goldstein, können Sie Ihre Stirn rundseln?
Stirn rundseln?
Ja, genau.
Ich kann die Stirn rundseln, das kann ich.
Können Sie Ihre Arme hochheben?
Arme, kann ich auch hochheben?
Ja.
Sie haben eine Unfertiglichkeit gegen Mieszucker
und haben Sie noch etwas als Allergien oder Unfertiglichkeiten?
Also ich vertrage auch so tropische Früchte nicht so gut wie Kiwi.
Ich kriege immer einen Brennen im Mund
und das esse ich schon lange nicht mehr.
Also hauptsächlich Kiwi vertrage ich nicht so gut
und ich habe eine, das wurde mal ausgetestet,
eine Allergie gegen Nickel.
Nickel, okay.
Wie aussehen Sie sich gegen Nickel?
Ich hatte mal einen Gürtel, die Gürtelschnalle am Bauch,
da hatte ich plötzlich so einen Ausschlag bekommen
und dann wurde das getestet
und sagte der Hautarzt, ja, das ist eine Nickelallergie
und seitdem ich das dann nicht mehr getragen habe
oder etwas Salbe genommen habe, dann ist das auch weggegangen.
Ist gut.
Und rauchen Sie Frau Wolstein?
Ich rauche nicht, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Das war sehr gut.
Und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, nicht so regelmäßig,
aber so jeden zweiten Abend vielleicht mal ein Glas Wein,
aber nicht mehr.
Ein Glas Wein, oder?
Und bitte nächste Frage, nehmen Sie nicht,
nehmen Sie nächste Frage nicht bei so einem Spitzte.
Diese Frage ein, eine nimmstige Frage, die ich zu jedem Patient fragen muss.
Also haben Sie schon einmal Drogen probiert,
posimieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, habe ich noch nie probiert.
Ja, ich wollte nur fragen, weil manche Drogen zu manche Beschwerden per Ursachen
und treiben Sie regelmäßig Support Frau Wolstein?
Zweimal in der Woche gehe ich Jobben, so 30 Minuten.
30 Minuten.
Und wie ist die Familie Stand Frau Wolstein?
Frau Wolstein, sind Sie verheiratet oder?
Ja, ich habe gesagt ja.
Ich bin ein Kind.
Keine Kinder.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Polizistin.
Polizistin.
Und haben Sie viel Stress?
Ja, das ist oft die Schichtdienst, auch oft Nachtdienste.
Das ist schon sehr anstrengend.
Und ich bin manchmal auch dann immer ganz schön erschöpft.
Hatten Sie eine Nachtschicht in der letzten Woche oder bevor diese Schmerzen aufgetreten sind?
Nein, da war eine normale Tagschicht.
Sehr gut.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch, Frau Wolstein?
Ja, der Vater, der ist 88 Jahre alt, der hat aber ein ziemlich schlaches Herz.
Er war auch immer zum Kardiologen gehen und bekommt viele Medikamente,
aber der kann sich gar nicht mehr groß belasten.
Er hat auch ein bisschen Alterszucker, aber hauptsächlich ist es die Herzschwäche.
Und die Mutter, die ist auch 88 Jahre alt, die hatte, als sie 65 Jahre alt war, da hatte sie Darmkrebs
und ist da auch operiert worden.
Aber es geht ja von daher gesehen gut.
Was Ihr Probleme macht, ist Arthrose in den Fingern und in den Knien und in der Hüfte.
Also, sie hat eigentlich überall Arthrose.
Deswegen kann sie sich immer noch mehr richtig bewegen und geht an einem Rollator.
Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen.
Und haben Sie Geschwister, Frau Wolstein?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Frau Wolstein, ich wollte nur mich bestätigen.
Also, haben Sie eine Yukreis bemerkt, vielleicht?
Yukreis am Körper?
Ja, genau.
Ganze Körper, oder?
Nein.
Wir sind am Ende dieses Gespräch.
Ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen, dann Ihnen ein Blut abnehmen.
Ich muss mit meinem Oberarzt über Iran falsch sprechen.
Also, dann werde ich wieder Sie zurückkommen und wir werden über Iran falsch sprechen.
Okay, dann müssen wir Sie...
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen eine andere Frage?
Müssten Sie Regal-Music Iran-Bulut-Druck?
Ja, das habe ich im Anfang häufiger gemacht.
Aber ich muss zugeben, in den letzten zwei Wochen habe ich kein Mal mehr gemessen.
Sonst mäß ich so ganz sporadisch vielleicht einmal die Woche inzwischen nur noch.
Ich weiß, dass das zu wenig ist, aber zuletzt war ich da etwas faul.
Ist Iran-Bulut-Druck mit dieser Medikamente gut eingestellt?
Ja, ich habe das...
Als ich häufiger gemessen habe, habe ich das dann auch aufgeschrieben
und meinem Arzt gezeigt und der war eigentlich sehr zufrieden damit.
Und auch vor einem halben Jahr war ich bei einem Betriebsarzt bei der Polizei.
Da wurde ich auch untersucht und das war auch in Ordnung.
Aber das ist schon, wie gesagt, etwas länger her.
Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Nein.
Trinken Sie ausreichend Wasser?
Trinken Sie ausreichend Wasser oder Polistik?
Ob ich ausreichend trinke?
Ja, ja.
Ich glaube schon, ich glaube schon.
Ich habe im Dienst auch immer eine große Flasche Mineralwasser im Auto,
wenn wir unterwegs sind, beim Nachdem-Sport und so weiter.
Ich glaube schon, dass ich genug trinke.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt Herr Oberarst.
Aber diese Frage, diese Frage erforderlich oder nicht,
ich weiß nicht, die Patiente hat gesagt, vertigo.
Schwarz vor den Augen müssen wir fragen, oder?
Ja, das sehen Sie.
Ich glaube, der Kollege hat, glaube ich, gefragt, ob ich das bewusst sein verloren hätte.
Haben Sie gefreut?
Ich glaube, der ist sein verloren.
Oder Schwarz vor den Augen.
Kresen, Kopf, Senkop.
Schwarz vor den Augen.
Aber gut, auf der einen Seite wurde gefragt, haben Sie Sehstörungen?
Das wurde gefragt, die Seestörungen wurden gefragt.
Es wurden Augen nicht bewusst sein, aber nicht vertigo zwischen.
Plesenkop gleich.
Ja, das kann man natürlich noch dazu fragen, das kann man noch ergänzen.
Das ist richtig.
Und es ist plötsch, ich weiß nicht, plötsch.
Erst die Übelkeit, die Übelkeit war ziemlich schnell mit den Kopfschmerzen.
Und dann kam auch bald das erste Erbrechen, das war sehr schnell, so sehr schwallartig.
Schwallartig, ja, schwallartig.
Könnten wir, ich ermensen, beschreiben diese Frage,
ist das korrekt?
Ja, aber wie sieht das Erbrochene aus?
Oder schwallartig, schwallartige.
Schwallartige, ermensen.
Erbrechen war schleimig, gelblich, aber kein Blut.
Kein Blut, aber schwallartig.
Ja, schwallartig.
Das heißt eine interkraniale Druckzeit, deswegen schwallartige Mesis.
Kann ein Hinweis sein, kann.
Noch andere Fragen, Kollegen?
Könnten wir Arsatzgeschichte anfangen, Oberarzt?
Ich glaube ja, der Kollege ist fertig.
Bitte schön, Herr Oberarzt.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt, ich habe eine neue Patientin übernommen, haben Sie Zeit dafür?
Ja, ich.
Frau Melanie Gorstein ist eine 58-jährige Patientin, die sich heute Abend bei uns wegen seit 3 Stunden
auf der Schmerz auf der Schmerzskala eingeladen hat.
Die Patientin berichtete, dass diese Schmerzen auf der Schmerzskala, 8 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala
seien und in Ruhe einwischen besser geworden seien.
Laut der Patientin gäbe es keine Auslöser der Schmerzen.
Sussistisch teilt sie mit, dass diese Schmerzen langsam bewohnen hätten.
Und sie habe dagegen eine Paracetamol eingenommen, aber das hat ihr nicht geholfen.
Schmerzen haben plötzlich.
Ja, plötzlich.
Ja, plötzlich angefangen.
Schmerzen waren ziemlich plötzlich da.
Ja, ich habe die beide geschrieben.
Ja, gut.
Ja, ich habe die erstmalig aufgetretenen HB geschrieben.
Und sie haben sich hinten auslösern aufgetreten.
Ja.
Und sie haben ihre Blutdruck nicht gemessen.
Verne sind der Patientin die folgende Begleitung aufgefallen.
Haben Sie den Blutdruck gemessen bei der Patientin?
Nein, ich sollte Ihre Blutdruck gemessen.
Aber ja, ich habe es vergessen.
Ich werde das schnell machen.
Gut.
Und sie klagt über ein Amorosis, nausäer, dreimal schwallartige Emesis
und vertigo.
Die Fragen nach Meningismus, Zynkoparesis, Parasitesi oder Trauma wurden von der Patientin verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unabfällig,
bis auf eine Inapätenz wegen dieser Schmerzen und Obstipation.
Anvorherkrankung.
Hat die Patientin Obstipation?
Hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Ja.
Oder?
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich nicht.
Obstipation habe ich nicht.
Was hat sie dort gesagt?
Ich konnte das ganz nicht verstehen, ich glaube damals.
Rühr, vor einigen Jahren hatte ich Beschwerden mit dem Stuhlgang,
Durchfall und Blehbauch.
Und dann wurde eine Milchzuckerunverträglichkeit festgestellt?
Ja, ich habe es auch geschrieben.
Und Reisdarm festgestellt?
Ja, am Vorherkrankten leide sie an.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, Reisdarm, Herr Heiko.
Ja.
Seit wann?
Ich weiß nicht.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, Reisdarm.
Also die Patientin hat berichtet, dass sie vor einigen Jahren Probleme hatte
mit der Verbrauchung, hatte Durchfälle, hatte Blehbauch.
Und dann wurde bei der Untersuchung eine Unverträglichkeit auf Milchzucker festgestellt.
Reisdarm haben Sie gesagt?
Ich habe verstanden, seit wann?
Nein, nicht seit wann, Reisdarm.
Reisdarm-Centrum, chronisch-entzündliche Darmenerkrankung.
Gibt es einen medizinischen Fachausdruck?
Oder man kann sagen, vielleicht Coulon irritabilé, könnte man sagen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Aber was die Patientin hat, die hat die Patientin gesagt, sie hat eine Amaurosis.
Also sie ist echt störend.
Sie hat gesagt, ich kann nicht mehr so gut sehen, ich sehe verschwommen.
Ich glaube, sie sagen dann besser, Patientin berichtet über eine Visusminderung.
Das ist besser als Amaurosis, weil Amaurosis ist da schon etwas gravierender.
Visusminderung, das heißt, willkommen eine Symptome.
Verschwommen ist sehen, sie sieht nicht mehr klar.
Sie sieht die Dinge nur verschwommen.
Das nennen wir erstmal Visusminderung.
Amaurosis würde ich da ...
Amaurosis nicht.
Er mir etwas zu hart.
Ich habe sie jetzt unterbrochen, bitte fahren Sie fort.
Kein Problem.
Momentan, Sie haben Oberast und Chefas, ich bin Facharzt.
Deswegen ...
Ja, ja.
Wie schön, schön.
An vorerklangten Genleide, sie an eine Arteriechipetone,
seit fünf Jahren, Freisdarm-Syndrom und Glöckum.
Aber ich habe es vergessen, seit wann haben, hat sie diese beschwerden.
Also der Rang des Glaucom, der grüne Starr, seit zwei Jahren.
Seit zwei Jahren.
Und sie wurde als Kind ...
... tonselektomiert und abendektomiert.
Und es wurde bei ihr auch eine Nierenoperation wegen Nierensteine
am linken Seite.
Naturalitiasis.
Ja, wegen einer Nephrolitiasis, ja.
Und in Besuch auf die Medikation Nehme,
Frau Gorstein, die folgende Medikamente,
regelmäßig ein,
weil Sartan fünf Milligramm Tablette, einmal morgens, einmal abends,
Metoprol, 25 Milligramm Tablette, einmal morgens,
wieder einmal abends.
Und Timoptol, tröpfend gegen Glaucom,
einmal die beide Augen, morgens, einmal die beide,
für die beiden Augen abends.
Okay.
Nein, bitte noch mal, was Sartan, wie viele Milligramm?
Fünf Milligramm.
Also Tant fünf.
Okay, gibt ... ja, okay.
Und der im Status sei verständig.
Und die Reiseanahmnese ist unauffällig.
Sie, sie habe eine Laktoseintoleranz.
Dafür haben sie ihre Ernährungsmethode.
Sie verändern.
Außer dem, sie habe eine Unverärglichkeiten
gegen tropische Flüchte, also zum Beispiel Kiwi,
die mit brennenden Mund sich äußeren
und eine Nickel-Allergie.
Ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden,
Gürtel, Schwallau da.
Es handelt sich wahrscheinlich um eine Kontaktallergie,
Kontakt der Matitis, und entsprechende Kontakt-Exem
oder Kontakt der Matitis.
Kontakt der Exem, okay, ich verstehe es nicht.
Sie sei nicht traurig, und trinke jeden zweiten Abend
ein Glas Wein, sie habe keine Kontakt mitgezogen.
Und als Sport, als Sport jog sie 2 Mal an der Woche
ungefähr 30 Minuten.
Und sie sei verheiratet und habe keine Kinder.
Und sie sei Polizisten als Beruf.
Also sie ist mit Stress ausgesetzt.
Sein Vater ist ihre Eltern, ihre Eltern leben noch.
Also ihr Vater ist 88 Jahre alt und leider an
Helsinki-Piscins und die Abit-Militustip Typ 2.
Und ihr Mutter ist auch 88 Jahre alt und mit 85
Lebensjahr alt an 65.
Wegen kolorektal Personum operiert wurden.
Und außer dem Leid desy an Gonarthrose,
Huxarthrose, der Patient sagte, sie leidet an
alle Arthrose-Typen.
Man kann sagen, sie leidet an einer Polyarthrose.
Polyarthrose.
Ja, ich wusste es nicht.
Ja, ist gut.
Okay, und sie sei ein sehr kind.
Die an einem Nistische Angabe, also auf der
erwähnten Symptome gehe ich von einer Entgleisendartere
Hypothonie aus.
Aber der Patient sagte zu mir, die Patientin sagte zu mir,
dass ihre Medikamente regelmäßig eingenommen habe.
Hat die Patientin Blutdruck-Selbstmessungen gemacht?
Sie sagte nein.
Die Patientin hat Blutdruck-Selbstmessungen gemacht,
früher regelmäßig.
Aber in den letzten 14 Tagen hat sie angegeben, hat sie nicht
mehr gemessen.
Ja, am Ende haben sie gesagt, ich will aber das.
Also hat Blutdruck-Selbstmessungen früher intensiver gemacht,
häufiger, aber in letzter Zeit eher nicht und zuletzt
ungefähr vor 14 Tagen.
Was gibt es denn für Differenzialdiagnosen?
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen die Folgenden im Betracht.
Stressbedingte, Kopfschmerzen, Migraine,
Meningitis oder Tia habe ich gedacht.
Als erstes würde ich dieser Patient natürlich
körperlich untersuchen.
Also ich sollte zuerst eine Wiedererrichterparamete messen.
Also Blutdruck messen besonders.
Dann würde ich neurologische Untersuchungen durchführen
und Blut abnehmen.
Also beide Läbo-Untersuche würde ich
CHP, BSG, Blutbild untersuchen.
Okay, differenzialdiagnostisch sollte man eins auf alle Fälle
noch in Erwägung ziehen, die Patientin berichtet,
dass sie einen Glaubkomb hat.
Ah ja.
Es könnte schon ein akuter Glaubkomb-Anfall durchaus
mit dahinter stecken.
Zumindest sollte man das auf alle Fälle Bedenken im Auge behalten.
Das wird dann oft vergessen.
Eine Kollegin fragte glaube ich hier im Chat, habe ich gelesen,
gerötete Augen oder ein gerötetes Auge wurde gefragt.
Ich habe das eben gesehen da unten.
Ja genau, Herr Seilmann hat geschrieben, haben sie roten Augen.
Ja, das habe ich kurz gesehen eben.
Also das Glaubkomb ist sicherlich noch differenzialdiagnostisch,
würde ich es mit erwähnen.
Soll ich Glaubkomb-Attacke schreiben oder sagen?
Wie bitte?
Man kann auch sagen, Verdachte auf akutes Glaubkomb-Anfall
oder Glaubkomb-Attacke, ja, kann man ruhig sagen.
Es gibt natürlich in seltenen Fällen auch dieser heftig einsetzende Schmerz,
der mehr, dann ist, es kann auch eine subarachnödelblutung sein, so was.
Ja, deswegen fragte ich Syncope Parisaparastisioda.
Neurologie, Neurologie so in der Sinne hat die Patientin ja nicht geboten,
bis auf, jetzt sagen wir mal, Schwindel oder Vertigo und rund.
Gut, was sicherlich, Sie haben das mit der Anamnese und so finde ich alles total gut
und systematisch gemacht und verständlich.
Aber denken Sie bitte dran, wenn jemand mit so heftigsten Kopfschmerzen kommt,
die seit drei Stunden bestehen und so was noch nie gehabt hat,
den würde ich sofort den Blutdruck messen, sofort.
Wir haben zwar gefragt, messen Sie den Blutdruck oder haben Sie den Blutdruck gemessen?
Da hat die Patientin gesagt, nein, habe ich nicht.
Da müssen Sie sofort als erstes dann die Vitalparameter messen und sagen,
Frau Goldstein, ich messe jetzt gerade, ich möchte noch ein Bild machen,
ich messe jetzt gerade Ihren Blutdruck und vielleicht Ihren Sauerstoff gehalten
und während ich Sie weiter befrage.
Und dann haben Sie schon mal sich gut gekümmert, das beruhigt auch den Oberarzt.
Und dann könnten Sie gleich vielleicht sehen,
Frau Goldstein hat einen Blutdruck von 250 zu 130.
Und da müsste man dann vielleicht schon während der Anamneseerhebung
vielleicht schon tätig werden.
Vielleicht den Blutdruck versuchen, mild und langsam,
vielleicht etwas zu beeinflussen, zu senken.
Ich glaube, das wäre für eine Prüfung wichtig, dass Sie einfach sagen,
ich würde jetzt die Anamnese unterbrechen und würde erst bei der Patientin
die Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Und dann setze ich die Anamnese fort.
Und ich glaube, dann sind erst mal alle sehr zufrieden und beruhigt.
Aber Sie haben die Anamnese, denke ich, auch gegenüber dem Oberarzt,
sehr ruhig und klar dargelegt und auch mit den notwendigen
medizinischen Fachausbrüten.
Auch wenn vielleicht ein oder was, nein, nicht da war,
aber Sie haben, denke ich, die aller, aller meisten sehr gut umgesetzt.
Ja, fehlt jetzt nur noch die Prüfung.
Amen, diese Monat.
Gut.
Das ist ja nicht mehr so lange.
So.
Ich hatte eine Frage, sodass diese Fall nicht, Düsseldorffalle, eine Frage.
Wir fragen, ob es Schleudertrauma oder Schiffhals,
welche werden gibt.
Schleudertrauma in der Anamnese?
Schleudertrauma und Schiffhals.
Ja.
Also, es wurde ja gefragt, hatten Sie einen Unfall oder ein Unfallereignis
oder ein Sturzereignis?
Das wurde ja relativ früh gefragt vom Kollegen.
Und das fand ich schon mal eine wichtige Frage.
Es kann ja auch mal sein, vor sechs Wochen ein Sturz
und dann entwickelt sich ein Subduralhematom oder irgendetwas,
was dann vielleicht nicht ganz so dramatisch,
vielleicht sofort diesen akuten Schmerz macht,
aber das ist eher so ein vielleicht ein schleichender Prozess,
so habe ich es zumindest erlebt.
Aber die Frage nach dem Sturzereignis oder gut das beinhaltet,
vielleicht auch ein Schleudertrauma.
Also, wenn eine Polizistin sagt, ich hatte einen Verkehrsunfall
vor zwei Wochen und nacken Schmerzen oder so, etwas klar,
dann ist das eine wichtige Hinweis.
Danke schön.
Vielen Dank.